[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter dumbledore's
phoenix fawkes wandlore and lord
voldemort
more specifically we're going to be
addressing a couple of things
number one why forks's phoenix feather
chose voldemort and number two
why fox's phoenix feather chose harry we
know that fawkes supplied the tail
feather for both harry and voldemort
ones and i've got a sinister theory for
why
harry first picks up his wand in
olivander's one shop right near the
beginning of the philosopher's stone
while accumulating supplies for hogwarts
a wand is the object through which a
witch or wizard channels his or her
magic
it is made from wood and has a magical
substance at its core ones made by
ollivander have caused a phoenix feather
unicorn hair or dragon heart string and
are of varying woods lengths and
flexibilities
as shown above ones come in a variety of
shapes colors sizes flexibilities and
materials
the main parameters that differentiate
each one are as follows
length wood type and lastly core type
each element is just as important as the
last and these numbered criteria are
part of the reason why each which
wizards wand is so unique
in fact there are a considerable number
of permutations
harry is ultimately given an 11 inch
wand made of holly with a phoenix
feather call but what's important to
note here is that he's not just given it
the one chose him in fact that's how
once work at least at olive enders and
part of the close bond shared by which
wizard and wand can be attributed to
this
wizards and ones share an almost
symbiotic relationship
and that's why someone's simply won't
work for certain people
but before finally landing on the one
that would choose him harry tried many
others harry tried and tried he had no
idea what mr ollivander was waiting for
the pile of tried once was mounting high
and high on the spindly chair but the
more once mr ollivander pulled from the
shelves the happier he seemed to become
tricky customer eh not to worry we'll
find the perfect match here somewhere i
wonder now yes why not unusual
combination holly and phoenix feather 11
inches nice and supple harry took the
wand he felt a sudden warmth in his
fingers
he raised the wand above his head
brought it swishing down through the
dusty air and a stream of red and gold
sparks shot from the end like a firework
throwing dancing spots of light onto the
walls
hagrid whooped and clapped and mr
ollivander cried oh bravo yes indeed oh
very good well well well how curious how
very curious
and what's so curious about this
situation is that the brother core of
harry's wand existed inside the wand of
another character you might know
lord voldemort
he put harry's wand back into his box
and wrapped it in brown paper still
muttering curious
curious
sorry said harry but what's curious mr
ollivander fixed harry with his pale
stare
i remember every wonder ever sold mr
potter every single one
it so happens that the phoenix whose
tail feather is in your wand gave
another feather
just one other
it is very curious indeed that you
should be destined for this wand when
its brother why its brother gave you
that scar
harry swallowed yes 13 and a half inches
you
curious indeed how these things happen
the wand chooses the wizard remember i
think we must expect great things from
you mr potter after all he who must not
be named did great things
terrible yes but great
so how is it that voldemort and harry
ended up with the same one core
what are the chances that these two
wizards whose fates would intertwine
ended up with phoenix feathers from the
same phoenix
we know later in the story that harry
and voldemort sharing a one core
inevitably ends up being an important
plot point
this is because of the effect produced
when the two ones are pitted against
each other in combat
they will not work properly against each
other said dumbledore
if however
the owners of the ones force the ones to
do battle
a very rare effect will take place
one of the ones will force the other to
regurgitate the spells it is performed
in reverse
the most recent first and then those
that preceded it
so it was always important from a plot
perspective that the two share a one
call
but why is it relevant otherwise and
provided that harry and voldemort are so
very different how is it that they could
end up with brother cause
according to pottermore the following
can be said of phoenix feather cores
phoenix feathers are capable of the
greatest range of magic though they may
take longer than either unicorn or
dragon cause to reveal this they show
the most initiative sometimes acting of
their own accord a quality that many
witches and wizards dislike
phoenix feather ones are always the
pickiest when it comes to potential
owners for the creature from which they
are taken is one of the most independent
and detached in the world
if phoenix feather cause are the
pickiest when it comes to potential
owners what commonalities do harry and
voldemort possess that could entice a
selection by the wand we learn to love
forks over the course of the harry
potter story and there's no chance that
his feather could possibly choose
voldemort right
well here's where it gets tricky i think
the simple answer is that if voldemort
were to visit ollivanders as well
voldemort and not tom riddle then he
would have never been selected by a
phoenix feather but the truth is that
when tom riddle visited ollivanders as a
young boy he was not yet entirely
corrupted
his path was still albeit inevitably
rocky unclear and this meant that there
was hope for this young boy
furthermore tom riddle possessed an
incredible amount of magical ability
which was no doubt alluring for the
powerful phoenix feather core
the core sensed power and it knew that
with this wizard it would be able to do
great things it knew that this great
power had a massive amount of potential
to do good
things just didn't end up working out
that way
furthermore provided that phoenixes are
symbols of death and rebirth it makes
sense that it would select someone like
voldemort a man obsessed with avoiding
death
similar to the way the phoenixes were
born from its own ashes voldemort
anchored his own life through placing
his soul into objects horcruxes which
tied him to the mortal plane and allowed
him to be reborn
voldemort simply perverted the meaning
of what transcendence really is
allowing lust for power to get the
better of him as for harry well i don't
think you can deny that he was destined
for greatness
you also certainly can't avoid the
similarities that harry and voldemort
shared in early life either
both orphans of mixed heritage with a
troubled start in life
even sharing a slight physical
resemblance they were just looking for
their place in the world
but for just a second
let me introduce you to a more twisted
perspective
the only reason that falk's feather
chose harry was because of his
connection to voldemort the night that
voldemort killed harry's parents a piece
of ultimate soul latched itself onto
harry cementing the connection between
them but what i want to suggest here is
that the core in the ones that chose
harry
only picked him because it was drawn to
the parasitic part of voldemort inside
of harry and did not harry himself
and the darker part of what this theory
would suggest is that harry wasn't truly
destined for greatness
in an interesting turn of events the
only reason that the harry potter was
great the only reason that he was a
person of interest in any way was
because of tom riddle
what do you think was harry destin to be
chosen by the fabled phoenix feather or
was it purely because of his connection
to voldemort
let me know down in the comment section
below
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you